digamos que tenemos una función f de x
que está definida por una serie infinita
que va desde que en es igual a 1 hasta
infinito y cada uno de sus términos es
de la forma x a la n 1 entre 4 a la n
por n a la 4 y bueno podemos escribir
los primeros términos de esta serie para
ver más o menos cómo funciona esta serie
entonces vamos a ver cuál es el primer
término el primer término lo obtenemos
cuando n es igual a 1 entonces aquí
tenemos x a la uno más uno y eso es
simplemente x a la 2 entre 4 a la 1 x 1
a la 4 y eso es simplemente un 4 y
entonces el segundo término es cuando n
es igual a 2 así es que tenemos aquí x a
la dos más uno que es un x a la 3
entre 4 a la n que ahorita estamos en n
igualados así es que tenemos cuatro
lados por n a la 4 o sea 2 a la 4 y
bueno aquí 2 a las 4 16 y 4 a la 2
también es 16 y 16 por 16 es 256 pero lo
vamos a dejar así más el tercer término
que es cuando n es igual a 3
tenemos x a la tres más uno o sea x a la
4 entre 4 a la 3 por 3 a la 4 4 a la 3
por 3 a la 4 y así podríamos seguir
poniendo un montón de términos más y así
está definida nuestra función
efe de x ok esta x de aquí está
determinada por en donde estamos
evaluando la función ahora lo que me
interesa a mí en estos momentos es para
que valores de x esta función
fx
sea para que valores de x esta serie
converge a un valor finito o sea lo que
quiero encontrar es el radio de
convergencia o el intervalo de
convergencia de esta función y como
últimamente hemos estado hablando del
criterio de la razón o sea del criterio
de la proporción o de la prueba del
cociente en este vídeo vamos a ver un
ejemplo en el que es muy útil
así es que preguntémonos para qué
valores de x esta serie convergen a un
valor finito y utilicemos el criterio de
la razón a ver para aplicar ese criterio
lo que tenemos que hacer es sacar el
límite cuando n tiende a infinito del
valor absoluto del término a n 1 entre
el término a n ok siempre hay que
recordar que el término n 1 va arriba
pero bueno en términos de este ejemplo
en particular lo que tenemos que hacer
es acá
el límite cuando n tiende a infinito del
valor absoluto y vamos a escribir al
término n 1 de este color el término n 1
de esta sucesión es x a la n 1 + 1 o sea
x a la n 2 entre 4 a la n 14 a la n 1
por n 1 a la 4 por n 1 a la 4 y ahora
vamos a escribir el término n en morado
así es que tenemos aquí el numerador y
tenemos que dividirlo entre el término n
que es x a la n 1 x a la n 1 entre 4 a
la n por n a la 4 4 a la n por n a la 4
y estamos tomando el valor absoluto de
todos
aunque ahora dividir entre esta fracción
es equivalente a multiplicar por su
inverso así es que todo esto lo podemos
simplificar como el límite cuando n
tiende infinito de este término lo
podemos copiar tal cual lo pegamos por
aquí y tenemos que multiplicar por el
inverso de éste
algunas personas le llaman a esto la
regla del sándwich pero bueno tenemos
que multiplicar por 4 a la n por n a la
44 n en 4 entre x a la n 1 x a la n 1 y
ahora podemos simplificar esta expresión
por ejemplo aquí tenemos x a la n 2 y
estamos dividiendo entre x a la n 1
así es que esto nos queda como x a la 1
y podemos dividir entre 4 a la n el
numerador y al denominador aquí nos
queda simplemente un 1 y por acá nos
queda un 4
eso sí no se nos olvide que estamos
tomando el valor absoluto en todos estos
límites y lo que nos queda es el límite
cuando n tiende a infinito de x entre 4
x entre 4 por n a la 4 en el a4 y este
término de aquí es un polinomio de grado
4 entonces desde la forma n a la 4 + 4 n
a la tres más un montón de términos que
tienen n a alguna potencia pero todas
esas potencias de n son más chicas que n
a la 4 lo que hay son aquí un bonche de
términos pero el único que nos va a
importar es este término n a la 4
entonces por aquí lo vamos a poner como
n a la 4
todos los otros términos que sabemos que
son términos de grado en el ah3n2 n y
una constante y no se nos olvide el
valor absoluto el chiste es que como
ahora tomamos el límite cuando n tiende
a infinito
todos estos otros términos de este
polinomio se van a ir a 0 no son
totalmente indiferentes porque en el
límite cuando n tiende a infinito lo
único que sobrevive son los coeficientes
de los términos que tienen el grado
máximo que en este caso es n a la 4 así
es que lo único que nos va a quedar es x
entre 4 la forma de probar esto es
dividir al numerador y al denominador
entre n a la 4 y entonces estos dos
términos se convierten en un 1 por su
coeficiente y todos estos otros términos
son coeficientes entre alguna potencia
de n los cuales cuando n tiende a
infinito se van a cero así es que este
límite es igual al valor absoluto de x
entre 4 y ahora si podemos ver que nos
dice el criterio de la razón o prueba
del cociente acerca de estas series
acerca de esta función porque ya
calculamos este límite y nos quedó igual
a x entre 4 y lo que nos dice este
criterio es que si el límite del valor
absoluto de la razón o proporción entre
el término n 1 y el término n que en
este caso ya vimos que es igual a x
entre 4 el chiste es que si este límite
converge a un valor estrictamente menor
que 1 entonces la serie convergen así es
que para qué efe de x converja a algún
valor finito este límite de aquí que a
la hora de sustituirlo es este límite de
aquí que ya calculamos que vale esto de
aquí tiene que ser
estrictamente menor que 1 y si tenemos
alguna equis que cumpla con esta
desigualdad entonces sabemos que f de
esa equis convergen a un valor finito
ahora esta desigualdad todavía la
podemos simplificar un poco más por
ejemplo el 4 el valor absoluto sigue
siendo 4 así es que esto es equivalente
a tomar el valor absoluto de x y
dividirlo entre 4 y que eso sea
estrictamente menor que 1 y bueno
también podemos multiplicar de los dos
lados de esta desigualdad por 4 y
obtenemos que el valor absoluto de x
tiene que ser estrictamente menor que 4
y esto de aquí tal cual es el radio de
convergencia radio de convergencia
con ver
ciencia
claro que si preferimos verlo como un
intervalo lo único que tenemos que hacer
es desarrollar esta desigualdad y nos
queda que x tiene que ser menor estricto
que 4 y mayor estricto que menos 4 así
es que este
intervalo
de convergencia
intervalo de convergencia y bueno estas
dos desigualdades son exactamente
equivalentes nos dan la misma
información y los valores de x que están
en este intervalo de convergencia o sea
que están en este radio de convergencia
son justamente los valores de x para los
que esta función converge a un valor
finito